depuis septembre 2021 pyongyang a déjà
effectué plusieurs tests militaires avec
des tirs de missiles balistiques et plus
récemment des missiles hypersonique
[Musique]
simple provocation démonstration de
force ou tests militaires que vaut
réellement l'armée de corée du nord on
vous répond dans facture
[Musique]
rappelons que la corée du nord est
encore techniquement en guerre il n'y a
pas eu de traité de paix signé entre les
deux corées depuis 1950 seulement un
armistice signé entre pékin et
washington et la corée du nord en 1953
avec un million deux cent quatre-vingt
mille soldats la corée du nord se classe
en quatrième position par rapport au
nombre d'hommes c'est juste après la
chine avec 2 millions 185 mille soldats
l'inde un million quatre cent cinquante
mille soldats et les états unis un
million trois cent quatre-vingt huit
mille soldats
existe même près de pyongyang une école
enseignants la fidélité aux plus jeunes
l'élite il serait formé tir fictif
idéologie politique et sport de combat
il serait enseignée
[Musique]
passons maintenant aux capacités
matérielles de pyongyang
[Musique]
selon la cia la corée du nord consacré
entre 20 à 25% de son pib à l'effort
militaire en 2015 le center for
strategic and international studies
évalué entre 3500 et 4000 200 le nombre
de chars que pyongyang détenait en
comparaison la france selon les chiffres
du ministère de la défense n'en a que 2
sans compter également 70 sous marins
contre 10 pour la france et 545 avions
de combat 215 pour la france si les
effectifs ils sont pléthoriques une
grande partie des capacités militaires
nord-coréennes sont vieillissantes voire
carrément obsolète et c'est notamment
pour cela qu'à connolly meurt à
développer ces dix vingt dernières
années ce qu'on appelle des capacités
militaires asymétrique c'est-à-dire
qu'elle ne peut plus aujourd'hui avoir
marine une armée de l'air ou même une
armée de terre véritablement haut niveau
face à la corée du sud l'équipement
vieillissant du matériel de l'armée est
compensé par développement accru des
missiles balistiques que l'objectif de
la colline ans d'avoir des missiles qui
sont manoeuvre on possible pour essayer
de pénétrer la défense antimissile
américaine est celle qu elle est donc de
pouvoir atteindre les cibles militaires
malgré les sanctions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu la corée du nord
continue de revendiquer des essais
nucléaires qu'en est il réellement sur
le terrain la grue du nord continue à
enrichir de et à produire de la matière
fissile c'est ce qui est indispensable
pour ensuite fabriquer assembler des
armes sous programme nucléaire
nord-coréen il se poursuit et c'est
évidemment une source d'inquiétude pour
la corée du sud pour le japon pour les
états unis mais plus largement pour la
communauté internationale puisque c'est
évidemment quelque chose qui va à
l'encontre de la non prolifération du
coup
et enfin maintenant quelles sont les
stratégies les alliés potentiels de la
corée du nord sur king peut-elle compter
en cas de conflit la cruelle non même si
les relations diplomatiques avec de très
nombreux pays contraints - souvent pensé
elle est assez peu de soutien entre
guillemets politique ou de soutien
militaire aujourd'hui la chine c'est
véritablement le partenaire principal
pour la corée du nord et les deux pays
en quelque sorte sont dans une situation
d'otage mutuelle si on peut le résumer
ainsi la corée du nord elle a besoin de
la chine pour ne pas s'effondrer et la
chine a besoin que la corée du nord ne
s'effondre pas entre guillemets les deux
pays se tiennent même si encore une fois
on n'est pas dans le cadre d'une
alliance aussi approfondi aussi visible
aussi démonstrative que ne peut l'être
par exemple l'alliance entre les états
unis à la corée dit nous voulons voir
que la corée du nord peut être une force
majeure lors de conflits armés malgré du
matériel vieillissant elle développe de
nouveaux programmes balistiques
faudrait-il encore que ses soldats ne
cherche pas déserté à travers la voix
démilitarisé
[Musique]